have you thought about killing yourself
nah not my cup I like life I mean I've
been sad I get depressed but uh that's
the part people forget is you're
supposed to get sad every now and then
everybody wants to be happy all the time
and take a pill and why is it all
working out it's like well you gotta
have the ups and downs yeah yeah even as
like being a successful person as you
are now you get depressed what do you
get depressed about it just hits you you
know and you start wallowing in it and
you start thinking about stuff and it
compounds and compounds wow you can't
get out of it you can't get out of it
yet but it will pass you got to remember
that it'll always pass yeah then the
good will pass too you're right I mean a
couple of months ago I was going through
some stuff and um you guys reached out
and thank you so much but
um I just didn't think that it would
pass yeah it feels like it was [__]
dark it was a dark time I'm like oh I'm
[__] you know it's like a bad trip
you're like this will never end yeah and
my sponsor will call me I go dude it's
gonna pass I promise everyone would say
it and then it just does I mean I mean
things change yeah yeah right but it's
like you adapt but it's like I um it's
almost made me happier in a weird way
yeah I know what you mean yeah I
survived it or whatever right yeah you
get stronger you're a little more
hardened like lizzo right now I think
it's probably going through [__] hard to
do some mental stuff yeah horribly and
just somebody uh like when Twitter
attacks you somebody equated it to being
thrown little toothpicks that stick in
you it won't kill you but after a
thousands of them they hurt yeah you
know yeah yeah yeah yeah it's so she's
probably not looking at social media
there's no way no she's not yeah yeah
what happened
um
I mean I know I I just it's just you
know vaguely I kind of know but I don't
know what the specifics are it's
basically like um a toxic work
environment some sexual like you know
inappropriate stuff but mostly with a
dance Captain yeah
um and um apparently some body shaming
um for some of the girls
um that's but but I think everyone is
just so involved can the girls body cam
shame back or no
yeah but I I I think people if you were
to really look into it like I'm sure
like everyone like we've all acted
pretty [__] up in our lives like I
just can't imagine this is worth maybe a
lawsuit no I think those girls hate her
she's probably a [__] because you have
to be to be this Arena Global household
name thing yeah so you gotta be like you
gotta snap you know hey do that you're
gonna crack the whip it do you well I
mean let me ask you something I mean
like for instance Bert
okay they're purchasing this gigantic
tour I'm not saying he's a nice guy yeah
but I'm not saying that he's a lizzo's
level but same body
all right let that sink in yeah well
you're right so my point is is that but
he is shooting he is doing large Arenas
and and stuff right yeah you know I I've
done stuff with him where it's like
there's staff and there's people that I
mean there's things that go wrong but
his nature is just a nice kind great
soft guy great guy he's a great guy yeah
but your nature is still bound to
conflict with somebody else's nature
like he could be you know like someone
could just not like his Vibe or take him
you know take it the wrong way or he's
having a bad day and he says one wrong
thing you just never know yeah but I
don't think that I don't know what Liz
was saying I don't want to argue because
I don't know much about it but what I'm
saying is this one bad day doesn't
equate to this world wind yeah it's a
pattern yeah yeah it's something that
goes on and on so I mean I hate to argue
with you but yeah I just feel weird
about like when people pile on yes I
don't want to play long I don't know
what I feel like you know like on say
for instance on Tick Tock well I'm lizzo
one time right now everyone has a story
about her yeah you're like yeah that
doesn't and it pisses me off because all
we preach is like compassion and mental
health and all that you're like you know
what this this [__] does to a person
that they're doing a lizzo like that is
[__] with her mental health yeah so
they're all full of [__] it's not just
[__] with their Mental Health
if she's a normal human being right and
she has all her feelings and you know I
mean
it's
the worst kind of self for human shame
right I I mean I I just can't imagine
the level I've been through it I have my
friends have been through it it's
[__] awful right and she's a way
bigger name she's getting way more
attention I can't imagine I can't
imagine either it's devastating yeah and
it's even sadder because they'll use the
sexual inappropriate that's all just
[__] they're like oh that'll catch yeah
we'll throw that out there whether it
happened or not people use those
important movements for their own
personal gain yeah which is really gross
yeah it's gross yeah it's well you know
let's pray for lizzo I guess hey there
you go great taste I mean I don't know
her music is it good t-shirts pray for
lizzo yeah is it good the music yeah
that's great I love it what do you like
uh you know I'm a nerd I like uh like
old old hip-hop or classic rock or
something like Punk okay yeah so I'm
gonna ask you some questions right real
quick okay yeah and you rank one through
ten if you like all right the Pixies